قالت دائره اداره الطوارئ والكوارثات
التركيه نزل زالا بشده سبعه فاصله اربع
درجات على مقياس ريختر ضرب ناحيه باسارجيك
من محافظه كرمان مرعش جنوبه تركيا وذلك
على عمق سبعه كيلومترات فجر اليوم وذكرت
هيئه الزلازل لان هزات ارتداديه لا تزال
تحدث في المنطقه وان هذا الزلزال شعر به
سكان المحافظات في جنوبيه تركيا ومدن
شماليه سوريا وذكرت وسائل الاعلام تركيه
نقلا عن مصادر محليه ان عددا كبيرا من
الابنيه تهدمت جرع الزلزال وقالت ان فرق
البحث والانقاذ لا تزال
تقوم باعمالها وتتوجه الان الى المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال من اجل انقاذ الضحايا
مشاهدينا نتابع واياكم من المفروض الان
صور اوليه
المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال هذه الصور
الاوليه التي وصلتنا والتي يمكنكم
متابعتها معنا نذكر بانها صور اوليه من
باسارجك هذه المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال
ينضم الي من غاز عنتاب مراسل الجزيره عمر
حوراني لمعرفه مزيد التفاصيل مرحبا عمر
المعلومات المتوفره
مرحبا يا هلا تفضل لا نحن في الطرقات جميع
الناس هرعت الى الطرقات انا اسكن في ولايه
غازي عنتاب جنوبيه تركيا وحدث هذا الزلزال
شعرنا بقوه كانت المبنى الذي اسكن فيه
تصدع بشكل كبير هرعنه
وهرعت
وهرى جميع الناس الى الطرقات الان جميع
الناس في الطرقات حاولنا الوصول الى
المناطق التي تحدثوا تحدثت على تحدثت
وسائل بانها سقطت بها ابنيه لكن حتى الان
لم نتمكن من الوصول كما تشاهدون هناك تخبط
كبير
الطرقات مغلقه
لكن يعني كما شاهدنا ان سيارات الاسعافرات
بشكل كبير كنا نشاهدها تت وتتجول في
المنطقه كما نشاهد تستطيعون
مشاهده هذه المناظر اود الحديث عن نقطه
مهمه ان هذا الزلزال جاء بالتزامن مع وجود
الثلوج هنا حيث خلال يومين مضت الثلوج
تساقطت بشكل كثيف في هذه المنطقه
وجميع الناس هنا في الطرقات قد يبدو هذا
المكان يتواجد فيه القليل من الناس الا ان
مررنا من احياء سكنيه مكتظه كانت جميع
العالم في الطرقات خوفا من حدود
هزات ارتداديه اثناء تواجدنا في المنزل
واثناء نزولنا من الابنيه كان هناك هزه
ارتداديه اخرى فقط حيث
هناك حديث كنت اتابع قبل هذا اشكره قبل
هذا البث كنت اتابع ان هناك
حلا ورود معلومات او في المواعيد
الاخباريه المقبله